one of the most famous events in the
Cold War was the Cuban Missile Crisis in
which a crisis occurred in Cuba
concerning missiles this saw the Soviet
Union place nuclear weapons in Allied
Cuba as you may know the USSR station
weapons in Cuba in response to the
United States earlier placing its own
nuclear weapons in Italy and turkey the
Soviets knew about the weapons in Turkey
they were Furious But ultimately they
didn't make a fuss about it like the
Americans did with Cuba which raises the
question why why wasn't there a Turkish
Missile Crisis after America station
nukes there so as of 1960 things between
the United States and the Union of
Soviet Socialist republics were getting
a bit tense and one of the things that
the US government had to concern itself
with was nuclear war and a part of
potentially winning said war was
reducing the amount of warning that the
USSR would get when the missiles were
launched and at the time there were two
main ways of doing this one developed
faster missiles which sounded hard or
two move the missiles closer the second
option was chosen when President
Eisenhower offered to store them in
turkey and Italy this was to reassure
them that America would be there until
editor the USSR from using nuclear
weapons against them the USSR learned of
these potential deployments in about six
seconds and Premier Nikita Khrushchev
routinely complained to the U.S Italian
and Turkish governments about their
deployment in 1961 when brand new not
shot President John F Kennedy was sworn
in it was his hope to find a long-term
mutual agreement to some of the issues
of the day as such he and Khrushchev met
in Vienna to discuss what could be done
this meeting went poorly Khrushchev
berated the new president calling him a
weak leader Whose actions across the
world were overtly and covertly hostile
towards his government and its communist
allies Kennedy had been toying with the
idea of removing the missiles from
Turkey but when Khrushchev issued the
Americans an ultimatum to leave Berlin
or face War he opted to keep them and
just over a year later Soviet nukes were
on their way to Cuba so why didn't the
Soviet Union publicly demand the removal
of nuclear weapons from Turkey in 1961
like the USA would do with Cuba the next
year well there were two main reasons
the first reason that the United States
could publicly demand that the USSR
seized their nuclear activities in Cuba
was that they thought that they could
stop it JFK's advisors didn't think that
nuclear the weapons were actually on the
island yet spoiler alert they were but
at the time the Americans didn't know
for sure and thus it was believed that
the USA's much mightier Navy could stop
the USSR from ever delivering them
furthermore the United States believed
that any event of award the U.S could
quickly overwhelm Cuba with an invasion
before the USSR could really react
whereas the USSR had no such beliefs in
order to remove the weapons from Turkey
the Soviets would have needed to launch
a major land Invasion this would attract
the rest of NATO into a war thereby
threatening the existence of Communism
in Eastern Europe and also such a
military buildup would have been spotted
long in advance and reason number two
that the USSR said nothing was well what
was new the USA already had long-range
missiles pointed at Moscow and since the
1950s it had fleets of long-range
bombers posted in numerous NATO
countries which were more than capable
of launching nuclear attacks against the
USSR the Soviet government was frankly
used to having American nuclear weapons
at high Readiness pointed at them and
making their existence publicly known
would do nothing but Panic the Soviet
people as such Khrushchev kept quiet and
used the Cuban crisis to get the
missiles removed from turkey and a
guarantee of Cuba's security which
frankly meant that after the crisis the
USSR had more in 1962 than it did in
1960. I hope you enjoyed this episode
with a special thanks to my patrons
James bissonnette Kelly moneymaker
kosher wolf Sky Chappelle cartoitska
Adams daughter Alex Schwinn Jerry
lambdin Marcus arsner rod D Martin a
firefly Y and hockey Captain psydog
boogly Wiggly Marvin cassau Winston
caywood commune Yoon Miss izet Maggie
Paskowski Gustav Swan the mcgwapa
Anthony Beckett Coppertone shewenin
spinning three plates words about books
podcast Jim Stromberg Spencer Lightfoot
and Charles the first